[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
all right let's try something else
[Music]
uh from the top ready one
two three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's c sharp orange
[Music]
two three i see you caleb
rachel no you forgot my socks mr g
okay she forgot her sack and now all
you county go for it
[Music]
hang on hang on what are y'all laughing
at so connie got a little lost in it
that's a good thing look i remember one
time my dad took me to this
jazz club and that's the last place i
wanted to be but then i see this guy
and he's playing these chords with force
on it
and then with a miner
[Music]
then he has the inner voices and it's
like he's it's like he's singing
and i swear the next thing i know it
it's like he
floats off the stage that guy was lost
in the music he was
in it and he took the rest of us with
him
[Music]
and i wanted to learn
how to talk like that that's when i knew
[Music]
i was born to play
[Music]
connie knows what i mean right connie
i'm 12.
i'll be right back practice your scales
sorry to interrupt mr gardner you're
doing my ears a favor
hey not you though you're good he's not
what can i do for you principal arroyo i
wanted to deliver the good news
personally
no more part-time for you you're now our
full-time
van teacher job security medical
insurance
pension wow that's uh great
welcome to the ms-70 family joe
permanently thanks
[Music]
after all these years my prayers have
been
right answered job working man coming
through yeah mom but i
you're going to tell them yes right
don't worry mom i got a plan you always
got a plan
maybe you need to have a back-up plan
too for when your plan falls through
a back-up plan never hurts joey we
didn't struggle giving you an education
so you could be a middle-aged man
washing your underwear in my shop
walking around with a hole in his pants
yep but this job you'll be able to put
that dead end
gigging behind you and lord knows we
need more teachers in this
world and just think playing music will
finally be your real career so you're
going to tell them yes
right please say yes
yeah definitely good
[Music]
hello how you been mr g uh it's curly
lamont lamont baker hey curly hey good
to hear your voice man uh yeah listen
uh you can call me joe now curly i'm not
your teacher anymore oh okay mr gardner
hey look i'm the new drummer in the
dorothy williams quartet
and we're kicking off our tour with the
show at the half note tonight dorothea
williams are you kidding me are you
kidding me congratulations man
wow i would die a happy man if i could
perform with dorothea williams oh well
this could be your lucky day
[Music]
[Music]
ah oh there he is
hey carly leon skipping town really put
us in a bind man
i'll bet glad you made it my boy bishop
said he uh sat in with you on the set
last year in brooklyn
said you were great well yo for a coffee
shop
[Music]
hit our theater this the cat i was
telling you about
my old middle school band teacher mr
gardner call me joe dorothea uh
i mean uh miss williams said it's a
pleasure
wow this is amazing uh
joe is ray gardner son so
we're down to middle school band
teachers now
get on up here teach we ain't got all
day
[Music]
what do we play
foreign
[Music]
uh sorry i zoned out a little back there
joe gardner where have you been i've
been uh
teaching middle school band uh but on
the weekends
you got a suit get a suit teach a good
suit
back here tonight first show's at nine
soundchecks at seven
we'll see how you do
[Music]
you know what that's going to say joe
gardner
you're never going to believe what just
happened i did it i got the gig
yes i don't know i know dorothea
williams
just don't tell my mom about this okay
forget class i'm in a different class
i'm in the dorothea williams class buddy
you know what i'm saying sorry
[Music]
what
[Music]
hello
hello
see what happens next order the entire
movie disney and pixar's soul
now available
you